hello ari hey steve what's going on hey
hey what's going on uh you're in new
york no where are you i'm in new york
i'm in new york rainy rainy rainy new
york
all right well let me just for those
many people know you uh you have a very
popular channel on youtube
uh and you speak chinese extremely well
i looked at some of your videos i found
them very interesting
and so maybe i could begin by asking you
it says somewhere that you are also you
teach chinese
you do these videos where you
a showcase your chinese skills but i
think
more important in a way you introduce
aspects of chinese food and chinese
culture to people who know very little
yeah about it so can i ask you
a little bit about your background
introduce yourself and and how you got
into doing all these things yeah so
so i would say um
[Music]
my like my background as it relates to
chinese
i
started studying chinese this sort of
the summer after high school i was a
little bit bored looking for something
to do
and so i just kind of saw an ad in the
paper for
a free chinese class
and i always knew that i liked studying
languages and i was good at it so i was
like all right chinese sounds like a lot
of fun
so i took that class
and it ended up being a really really
great experience
i continued studying
you know in college um
sophomore year of school i was like um i
ended up getting a scholarship to go to
china learn chinese um work can i stop
you for a second can i stop for a second
so why would someone offer free chinese
lessons is this a way to get you in the
door for further chinese lessons it's
the wave it's just the way for the for
the chinese government to promote the
study of chinese international okay
chinese government yeah right okay um
so sorry so then so then you went to
china
so they're handing out they're handing
out um you know scholarships to
foreigners to go to to go to china to
learn chinese i went to china spent a
year
in beijing
um i really enjoyed my time there
um and this was what year again just
like 2010
2009 2000 2009 2010 academic area
so yeah um
so loved it
came back to the states and i kind of
had like the language learning bug at
that point slash chinese culture bug so
i started sort of started making like
videos on youtube just like little
language learning videos and
and accent videos and just kind of like
fun things and i like doing that but i
didn't i never really kind of took it
seriously until maybe a couple years ago
when i i started doing this channel uh
full time um
yeah so that's like the 30 second
elevator version but happened to happy
to get like it's in more detail you know
on any of these okay yeah okay so before
we get into your uh videos which are
very entertaining and i think people
will enjoy looking at them
um chinese uh a lot of people think
chinese is very difficult
uh how difficult did you find it and do
you have any advice for people who
either are in the middle of trying to
learn chinese or have contemplated
learning chinese right yeah so that's a
great question so i would say
i think that in english-speaking
countries we tend to view
chinese as like the the pinnacle of
intellectual ability right if you can
speak chinese then you must be the
smartest person on earth which anyone
like any non-chinese person who spent
time studying chinese can tell you
it's kind of nonsense like chinese is
not i guess learning to write is once
learned to write and read as one is a
whole separate beast but
actually learning to speak chinese is
not really the hardest thing on the
planet you know um it's i think the
biggest difficulty for for non-native
speakers getting over is the tones
initially um
you know but but i think that like
you you can
you know the grammar i would say
relative to other you know languages i
studied is actually fairly similar to
english um
the uh there's a couple weirdness weird
things there but there's also a lot of
things that make it easy to learn so
honestly like it's not like i was i had
spent like i had learned a year of
chinese before going to china but i was
like conversationally fluent in chinese
within a few months i would say of
starting to live in china
um okay but but the fact remains i mean
i study chinese and to me there's really
two issues one is the characters and the
other is the tones
so i mean every language has uh those
things that are difficult if you get rid
of the things that are difficult then
it's easy but you're still left with the
things that are difficult
so
um
a how did you tackle the tones and b how
did you tackle the character right so
i would say with tones um
with tones i kind of i kind of have a
like a a jail
what's it called get out of jail free
card with that one to be honest like
i've always been good at at languages
and accents and so that just kind of
came very naturally and easily for me um
i will say
and i know a lot of i know it's very
difficult though for a lot of people and
and something that's helped me and other
people in the past get over that um
is
is like audio repetition so
listening to like recording yourself
speak and then playing it back with with
native references to whatever you're
saying
um is super super helpful for for trying
to understand where you're where your
tones are wrong and where your accents
wrong
and you definitely you need to do that
but you also just need to practice like
a ton like if you want to get good at
tones i mean you you can speak like i
definitely know foreigners have spoken
chinese for a long time and still have
really crappy tones but like that's the
first step right the first thing you
have to do is is speak and then you're
going to notice that your tones are not
good so
the way to get that the way to get over
that i feel like is through deliberate
practice with
practicing your own tones and comparing
it to
two native speakers um as far as as far
as characters
that one
that one definitely did not come as
naturally for me like first of all my
handwriting is really bad so i've never
been like i haven't been good with with
with with
with just writing things and like eye to
hand memory that's not one of my strong
suits um
so
with that i would say i just kind of
tried to focus on like i tried to i
tried to like separate what was
important to me and what wasn't so
pretty early on i decided like there's
no way i'm ever going to be able to
write chinese well like that's just not
it's just not in the cards you know like
i am not a calligraphy guy so so you
know what i was like and i know that in
introductory classes they really try to
stress like stroke order and you know
you got to get the form right all this
stuff but like i i was
i just didn't want to focus that because
there were things that were more
important to me so i made kind of a
decision early on to not focus on that
and focus more on just recognition and
recall and so which i think is much more
important for reading
um
and uh you know just just all the stuff
you do in day to day life in chinese
even for even for texting if you're
typing in chinese you're probably typing
with pinyon
which which which is basically all
recall all you need to know is how the
character sounds and then when you type
it in it's going to come up and as long
as you can recognize if that's the right
character you're good so um
so i just kind of focus on recall and
the way that the way that i got good at
that and i'm still not like the best at
recognizing chinese characters and
reading chinese but um
you know
the the the way that i the way that i
got to the level where i am now which is
that i can comfortably read more stuff
that i want to read on a daily basis um
is
one you know lots initially it was lots
of anki just lots of straight
memorization of characters you know it
sucks but like you got to do it you just
got to just memorize a whole ton of
stuff um
and uh just using it in context you know
like when i would use certain characters
i like i think there's there's some this
one school of philosophy that says all
right you just gotta memorize the kanjis
individually and like you know
it just makes just like
just like uh you know you can figure out
like what the original meaning is and
that'll help you remember for me that
never worked i just tried to memorize
the words like and then i would learn
from that i would learn in context with
the original what like individual
characters
would mean you know because chinese
language of words not characters so like
that that was the way that i tried to
memorize things and then learn the
characters from there
right i mean everyone has their own
approach i must say with regard to the
tones i focused a lot on listening
and in particular i listened to the sort
of xiangshang comic dialogues where they
tend to exaggerate the tones
i didn't really try to listen to myself
too much because i didn't want to become
too self-conscious
and i think you got to be a little
careful
in terms of an accent if you spend too
much time listening to yourself you get
self-conscious
whereas i found that if i just let it go
and but you have to do a lot of
listening if you if you just speak with
people every now and again you'll
continue to have poor tones but i think
you can train yourself to get better at
them and on the characters i agree with
you i have poor handwriting but when i
was studying chinese we had to write we
had to write for my final exam i had to
be able to translate newspaper
editorials from english into chinese so
the only the only uh
you know objective was to make sure
people could read what i had written it
didn't have to look nice
but you're absolutely right nobody
writes today i mean i similarly in
japanese or russian i never write but i
use my computer so i can communicate you
know
writing on the computer but but but i
did find that writing the characters out
by hand helped me learn them but i agree
i had a terrible and terrible
handwriting
uh and i also agree that that chinese i
mean i i think learning any language is
not a matter of intellectual achievement
it's simply a matter of of allowing
allowing yourself to you know not resist
the language and allowing it to enter
your brain and
just letting go and so none of these
things are necessarily a sign of great
i'm sure it wouldn't be hard to find
some very you know high iq professors
say foreigners in the united states or
canada who have who speak with a very
heavy accent for example so i don't
think fluency
in a language is necessarily a sign of a
high iq anyway
so you learn chinese
and now what got you into these very
entertaining and i really encourage
people to go and look at them and you're
getting like three four five or more
million views
for these videos
and it's it's it's
what okay let me ask you this to what do
you attribute the appeal of your videos
yeah
to be honest i initially you know i was
sort of a little bit surprised by it i
think that i think that one thing
one thing that i've learned is that
i think i think people
i think people want
some sort of inspiration when
they're they're learning languages like
they want to be able to see
a goal you know like they want to be
able to see like what what what what
can't like what's the point of learning
a language like why why should i even
bother spending all this time with these
textbooks and like
listening drills and like like why do i
even care you know
so like i think what my videos
let people do is is give them a reason
to care right like if you learn a
language if you learn a new language
you're getting a new personality you're
getting a new soul you're getting a new
way to like
to like interact with a huge number of
people
on this planet that
previously you just weren't able to do
and so like i think that in my videos
you know i'm able to show like what it's
like to
to have
meaningful interactions and
relationships with people
that
pre that for someone like me just
growing up in the us with only english
as my native language
would otherwise have been impossible had
i not
learned this language um right so
so i think that i think that um
uh yeah you know and and people message
me all the time just just saying like
saying
saying that these videos help them like
inspire them to want to learn mandarin
or other languages and um
yeah so i keep doing them i i think yeah
what i think is great in them is that uh
i think for the average new yorker
walking down the street seeing some
chinese food vendor
i consider them to be
sort of very distant very exotic very
strange
may not want to even
buy anything from them and so you bring
these people closer you you you approach
them and and they come across as being
very of course they're human but we see
them as very strange and we bring it it
just creates a sort of a sense of
familiarity
with
chinese street vendors chinese culture
chinese food so i think that's a really
good uh a really good service it is
interesting to note though that
for a westerner to go and speak to some
people
say in chinese on the street
is curious interesting whatever
i'm trying to picture a chinese or a
japanese person goes to the states and
does videos of going around speaking to
people in english yeah that wouldn't be
very interesting at all nobody would be
interested in that
so it does it is a reflection of how
um i guess people in china and japan get
much more exposure to western culture
western people western things and we get
much less exposure to them and their
culture and therefore they're perceived
as more strange
and therefore when you go there and you
just you know re interact with them
naturally in their language it's
perceived as something
interesting whereas the reverse wouldn't
necessarily be the case sure yeah i
think that's very true i think another i
think another factor contributing to
this is that
i i think that i think that there's
there's
whether it's due to the monolingual
status
of english in
you know many western countries
or
or what have you
the um
i think there's something about language
learning that
is is kind of prized as as sort of like
a good in its own like
regard in in western countries whereas
in these videos i've noticed like i my
chinese
or people and my asian fans from asia
are not as interested in them as
my western fans and i i think that i
think that there's something about like
you know
sorry they're not interested in in what
like my my f like these these types of
videos where i you know interact with
people in the street in chinese oh i see
with me yeah there
and i think that part of that is is that
in asia
language learning is not necessarily
like it's regarded as something
like you know you should learn english
because it can help you get economic
opportunities but it's not necessarily
regarded as something cool or something
like just
i i think there's there's a thing in
american culture where you know maybe
it's maybe it's all the movies you see
when like some guy busts out like seven
different languages and like you know
it's like james bond speaks like french
spanish or whatever like there's just
something cool about it that i think is
is is sort of inherent to
to
uh you know western culture that is not
necessarily like it's not necessarily
regarded as like a pinnacle of
intellectual achievement in china to be
able to speak really good english like
yeah yeah
so
i i would say that uh i would have to
disagree i think that
that in the west and of course the west
is not just north america the west is
europe the west is uh whatever
um speaking uh many languages is valued
and it's also valued in asia we had a
polyglot conference in fukuoka and there
were a lot of people there from
asian countries japan china korea
indonesia
whatever who spoke many languages i
think that the difficulty is
most people are not prepared to put the
effort in most people would like to
speak
one other two other three other
languages
when they discovered that it's a lot of
work or at least a lot of time
then a lot of people are discouraged or
because they use methods that are not
very effective but i think generally i
don't think there's that much difference
uh my interaction with people from asia
they're as appreciative of people who
learn languages yeah
uh as as we are i don't see a big
difference there except that uh i would
even go as far as to say that in north
america someone who speaks a lot of
languages is considered a bit freaky why
would you want to do that
to some people to some people but but
hey everywhere you got all kinds of
different people but at any rate you
know
i think it's great to see and you're
learning uh fuji hua or taiwa as well
yeah
and um
yeah that's what i've been learning most
recently which which i think i think
like back on the theme of engaging with
people's cultures like for me right for
me like the reactions that i get from
people
when i can speak fujonese with them as
opposed to mandarin
are are just so much greater i i think
that peeps when you're saying fuji why
you're saying in taiwan no no in new
york
oh in new york yeah okay yeah yeah okay
yeah lots of people lots of people in
new york speak fujonese
um oh i see yeah which is which is kind
of like one of these weird accidents of
geography but um
yeah it just it just happens like that
so how about the cantonese i speak a
little bit cantonese too um
which i use in my videos sometimes um
just because there's like in new york
probably outside of mandarin the two
biggest chinese languages that people
speak are fujians and cantonese uh oh
okay
yeah but so
okay
no just to end up here we should go on
for quite a long time so where are you
gonna what do you do or intend to do
with all of this where does this lead to
are you just gonna continue making these
videos or
i see where you're teaching chinese on a
voluntary basis in new york yeah yeah
yeah
um yeah that's that's just kind of like
for fun and you know it's nice to give
back to the community but um
you know
yeah i don't that's a great question i
don't know i don't know where it goes i
i mean i you know like if you had asked
me a year ago
or two years ago what i would be doing
in a year
from that point
i wouldn't have any idea um so
to me
trying to make long-term plans is like
it's like trying to nail jello to a wall
like i don't know what i'm gonna be
doing in a month from now um you know so
yeah so the the only thing that i'll say
is just you know i i want to keep
making things that
you know that can help
share cultures and languages throughout
the world and just be able to bring some
kind of like inspiration and joy to
people's lives and and motivate people
to learn chinese or other languages and
um you know for me i get a lot of you
know like happiness and
and pride out of doing this so
um yeah
well i recommend people go and visit
i'll leave a link in the description box
uh listen to this yamaha speaking
different languages and uh bridging the
cultural divide anyway thank you very
much for chatting with us thank you so
much appreciate it okay bye
[Music]
you